your back we're gonna have a cool gamer
today I'm playing a new reimagining of
the classic game crash team racing this
is Crash Team Racing nitro fueled you
know I'm saying and we're with Billy
Eichner who is a delightfully funny
gentleman's very nice thank you cuz
seriously I didn't mean it right
oh are there gonna I see they're working
and we're talking at the same time hmm
sort of problem this has never happened
in all the time a gamer we're getting no
signal something's going wrong see what
are we gonna do we have 4.2 yeah I think
it's honestly you're fired get out okay
say something Billy was clean-shaven
Billy if this doesn't work I will take
you to a nice dinner I would love that
bye nice dinner woody what does that
mean to you nice dinner I like a steak
would you want to go to waste this is
leur we can do a sizzler I used to my
family and I love sizzler when I was a
kid and we are not getting paid by
sizzler although of now subsequently
they wish to throw us a bone we have 45
people I mean look at this I mean I
haven't seen a tech team scramble this
country once went to the moon yeah we
went to the moon you guys are good a
video game working look at us now
oh-oh-oh-oh
doesn't happen because you're in your
50s
Oh didn't work out you know that thing I
said when we were yelling about an
orgasm just joking around wait I think
we have some success here right yeah
Island a fictional island in the south
of Australia where kind of mutant
animals such as crash and his friends
and humans can kind of coexist together
they're called the women Islands they
wait do you there do you think there's
interspecies mingling that's what I'm
asking what the parts like match up
alright don't do that that was the worst
mime I've ever seen yeah that's a mime
that gets arrested yeah you're gonna be
over here Conan yeah you just tell me
when there's a character you like okay
I'll take that guy okay yeah he's a dog
with bad teeth he's a he's a dingo dial
he's half dingo half crocodile oh so
they did mingle so somewhere a dingo is
the dingo dog had sex with a crocodile
this goes to Europe well now I'm hard
we're going for you talking but it was
time to go we're going there we go yeah
Billy where are you I'm right where are
you I'm right now I'm on the grass wait
for me
[Laughter]
it's the 15th anniversary or you just
set the movement back this is not right
wait for me I'm gay we're means that was
the original name of rocket
[Music]
I don't feel seen now look let's talk
about it I do want to acknowledge that
during that match things weren't going
well for you
no and you shout it out wait for me I'm
gay do you really feel like that's an
appropriate slogan is that gonna help is
that gonna help move the puzzle piece
for yes that's Pete Buddha judges
campaign I think we should up this ante
here so what we're gonna do is whoever
loses this next round has to let's bring
it in here where the head of the
Bandicoot oh it's been supplied we
didn't just have this sticking around I
used to have one from college but yeah
Boston has to wear the head of the
Bandicoot and plug humbly the other
players latest project you cool with
that
yeah get some Wampus it's an immoral one
poor fruit you come you come for tea
yeah me too
[Music]
wait up I'm straight Billy I was in the
Lion King July 19 big cast in that one
yep very exciting
congratulations to Billy Eichner thank
you and of course Crash Team Racing
nitro fuel is available June 21st on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and Nintendo
switch and yes I have grown children
let's do it you look like a furry I've
ever heard of us yes I have alright
actually had I've done well in the furry
community I'm sure
[Applause]